واسطه حضور دوليا واقليميا كبير يستعد
السودان لتوقيع على الاتفاق الايطالي بين
قاده الجيش وقوى الحريه والتغيير وستنضم
للتوقيع احزاب سياسيه من خارج الحريه
وتغيير لكنها تدعم عمليه تتحول للنظام
مدنيين ديمقراطي فيما تتخلف عن التوقيع
بعض الحركات المصلحه اهمها حركه العدل
والمساواه بدعمه وزير الماليه الحاليه
جبريل ابراهيم وحركه التحرير السودان
بقياده حكم اقليم دارفور مناوي عن الاتفاق
الموز مع توقيعه ينهي ازمه سياسيه تجاوزت
العام خلفها تولي الجيش او خلفها تولي
الجيش السلطه في الخامس والعشرين من
اكتوبر العام الماضي واعلاني حاله الطوارئ
وحل الحكومه واعتقال بعض القيادات
السياسيه كما يمهل الاتفاق الايطالي
لتشكيل حكومه المدنيه جديده من كفاءات
مستقله تدير الفتره الانتقاليه البالغه 24
شهرا بدءا من توقيع الاتفاق وتنتهي باقامه
الانتخابات للتحول الى نظام ديمقراطيه
برلمانيه
[موسيقى]